hi I'm Rodrigo Londo I teach computer
science at the TCS School of Computer
Science at Columbus State University the
name on my talk is chasing class
transitions in real space cellular
automata grow spaces and the talk is
basically about finding the transitions
between class behavior in the row space
okay I'm gonna start the talk so my name
is Rodrigo bondo I put Columbus State
University I'm then title of my talk is
chasing class transitions and cellular
automata rule spaces synapse strike and
you can actually read that in a window
whatever is going to be posted and
passable but basically the cellular
automata has been used since in 1950s
when a bond john-boy Norman you know
started for the with this idea of you
know investigating artificial life etc
there was not much research done you
know on and off throughout the decades
until war from started in 83 and he
started publishing a lot on that and
there were some other people that
continued doing some work and that in
this it is used to investigate complex
systems and that is mainly or not not
mainly but it's one of the reasons what
it's used the cellular automata so what
happens with this is that whenever we
looked at the are the rule spaces you
know how many how many rules so cellular
automata we have given certain
parameters we find that they can be a
lot and then there is the what is called
the elementary cellular automata which
is only has defined two colors and only
in one neighbor and each side and it's a
single in a one dimensional cellular
automata that actually has just 256
rules and that is actually you know
relatively easy to look into because
there are not too many the problem is
when you increase either the number of
colors or you also increase the nominal
neighbors that you consider in the
evaluation then those numbers become
much much larger and these two examples
in here and now I don't know how to do
this that's strange
now I have a question the two fingers
not enable in this notebook yeah it
should be well maybe it's not detecting
my two fingers oh there you go
there you go got it sorry alright
so for instance the two colors one
neighbor is 256 and we say well let's
just use two neighbors and that goes to
4 billion now explore in that particular
space is a little bit daunting and then
let's say we say the only one neighbor
but we use three colors and now we go to
seven trillion and then so explore those
spaces normally it's been simply out of
the question and Santa Fe Institute of
the Santa Fe Institute in New Mexico
where they do complex systems and
investigations etc you know for a long
time they always just did random
searches into the space so I got
interested in this you know some time
ago beginning of the 2000s and I started
looking into something like this so the
parameter ation of the rules you know
parameterization you use that to have an
idea of how you know to know where those
particular rules are and one of the most
known for arbitrations is the
limestone's lambda he proposed that in
1986 and the basically you know what he
said is to identify one of the two
states at the non active state and then
the output of the rule you know which is
normally a binary number in in in binary
the number of ones divided by the total
number of bits will give you the lambda
and then you start in the parameter you
know sort of what's useful and sometimes
depending on how you traverse the space
you know will give you some meaningful
information and will actually give you
places where you will transition in
between rural behaviors etc you know but
then most people you know all agree that
doesn't really work as well as he wanted
to even I heard that long term himself
has said that doesn't really work how I
wanted it so that was well one of the
problems with that so what I did is in a
a Polish dish and I think it was 2015 a
paper where I actually read the the
rules instead of considering the whole
rule I partitioned the rule into
primitives and if you're interested you
know I can give you the reference that's
actually published in complex systems
and I use something a little bit
different from that and these are just
taking parts of the rule and they are
not just split the writing in in half
but there are certain ways to to do that
for instance we call the primitive zero
is the subset of the rule where the
central cell is zero and the primitive
one is the subset for the central cell
is one so in this case you can see and
I'm going to move over there you see
that this two and this two are in fact
you know this first two in this what are
you this to our primitive zero and this
for our primitive one so that's how I
divided it because I was interested in
looking at the change in the rule so
whenever there is a change in in in the
state of the cell instead of just
looking at the numbers of ones which is
what Langdon's lambda was proposing and
it didn't really really work that well
so what what I did was out for instance
if you if you look at rule in the two or
four is they dented the rule and there
is no change and that's what is the
identity rule whatever you put into into
the into the cells that's what it
outputs for the next step but rule 51 is
the complement rule but that means every
single bit or every single cell will
change to the other state you know and
then this is the rule plot that
display that comes in and Mathematica
you know so that you can see each one of
those so what I found is that I wanted
to look at each one of those particular
ones or the the ones that actually flip
or change the cell and then I found that
I could sort of classify them and I give
them labels and for instance if for
primitive zero if both neighbors are
zero and the next step is going to be a
one that I call it a create because you
have two zeros and now you have a one
and if you have you know one on zero on
the right and one on the on the left and
then you actually change you know or one
on the on the right and then it changes
to one then it's actually a move or a
left and the other one is a right and
whenever you have two ones that actually
becomes a one in the central cell I call
it a merge and this is just for labeling
purposes
so I created a function that I created
you know that gives me the activity in a
case of activity 51 51 is the complement
you can see that it actually contains
all those functions it has the merge the
right the left under create and also the
primitive one has the merged is a right
the left and they create whereas 204 has
nothing and it actually makes sense 204
is supposed to be the identity it's not
supposed to do any and it make any
changes so when I look back back in 2004
and there was the second nks conference
I presented this because I look at those
things and I partition them and I look
at that that's the space of the 256
elementary cellular automata and this
are the world from classes and you could
see that the green you know its class
one the yellow is close to the violet is
class three and this other one is class
4 so I could see that there was a
structure in there and some people tell
well you rearranged those things you can
actually get any structure but I was not
yes you Iranian air because I wanted to
make it fit but it still at that time I
had not gone deep into that in fact that
that summer I went to the the nks summer
school
and I started looking into those things
anyway and this is where I hope that I'm
gonna be able to make this one work I've
been fighting with version 12 you know
the differences and hopefully I will be
able to show this this is supposed to
show an updated version of that that
particular view before this one not that
one
there you go it's coming
thank you so as you can see here this is
the same you know not the same but it's
a it's a rearrangement now of those
rules and we can see that the green on
the top ones and the the two columns
over here if they are symmetrical around
along the diagonal there are all
class-one all the Blues are class 2 and
class 3 are primarily in the middle and
then here we have class 4 to 110 124 and
all the the equivalent class which are
in that in that particular place now
when we look at this and then I look
back at lanterns
Langton spirometer was actually moving
from here all the way from this bottom
over there
so as it was moving with the parameter
it was actually sampling all kinds of
behavior so one dimension was not enough
to really capture that but when you look
at now the number of those functions you
know the merge the left the right and
they create if you find you know this
our order using though the number of
functions you find in here and I know
that it's very small but the very top
row has no activity on primitive one and
it doesn't matter what you do in terms
of the activity on primitive zero it's
always class one it's almost true also
for the second row only for this one
here where you also have not only merge
one but also have create zero and that's
the only one that it gives you a little
bit of you know sort of class to
behavior but in generally the the two
top rows and although the two columns
will give you class one so here is where
you see where there is a transition in
between the different class behaviors
and we find the interesting thing as you
move down
column by column when you get to this
particular row it says create zero is
the one that first has some interesting
behavior so as you go down you actually
find +4 behavior which is this one here
in class 4 and in this case 110 it has
only three of those functions and those
the only thing necessary for that which
is create one and how to move on the on
the sub 0 or emerge in a left and that's
all he needs to actually create the 110
or class 4 behavior so as we move along
we can actually find plus 30 around here
which is oddly enough is simply a create
one for the left one and a right 0 for
the left 0 and that is all you need to
create the class 3 in this case but as
you can see all the class 3 or most of
the class 3 are right in the middle of
the space so whenever you reach certain
number of those functions in the in the
and the rule all you get mostly is class
2 so what I'm trying to do is to
actually go to the bigger space the 4
billion and be able to parameterize
those or the functions which are
actually 16 per primitive which will
then be it will create 65535 possible
columns and rows I'm going to display
that you know that's 4 billion now we'll
have to use a very big image to even
with 1 pixel you know put the the
behavior on that but I can Explorer you
know before because we thought because
of Lantern's idea I believe I don't know
how to prove that that we thought that
the space of the the
the class behavior was randomly
distributed but it's not I can see here
that we can we can do these things and
see where in the space we find the
different classes so if you put too much
activity there is a point for your class
it's just going to be class too so most
interesting activity is if you consider
random or class three it will be right
in the middle all right so you could
look at these habits here just to
explore each one of the rows and if you
continue changing me she goes class one
and here you have still class one here
you have a little bit of class two this
is going down on the same on the same
one and then you finally get to this one
and that's what you have a little bit
more interesting which is class 4 class
2 class 3 etc we can also look at and
I'm not sure from ok look at your
subsets of those columns and rows and
then you see this actually when I looked
at that and I said I'm gonna look at
certain functions like no no functions
merge merge and write virtual left merge
right and left and finally all of them
together and when I put that you know on
the column which by the way those are if
you go back to the boolean expressions
those are monotone boolean functions
which the first graphic that I show in
2004 it's just that I that's what I was
trying to show that there is some sort
of relationship with the monotone
boolean functions in class 4 it's not
totally true of course but I I could
have I I was able to see that before and
this is the complement of that which is
you know just flipping it around
instead of doing that on monotones
on on the top you actually do monotones
on the column and actually give you the
compliment of the space alright so one
of the things that I wanted to do of
course is going to the 2 to the 32 rule
space and I want to be able to show that
actually continues having that kind of
behavior and let me see if I can make
this one a little bit bigger
unfortunately this was one of my my
issues that I had with with this new
version so I had to change some things
in here but what this one allows me to
do is first of all I have a lattice on
the left this rules are on the ECA these
are in the and the elementary automata
the changes in between this each one of
this is one bit in the row so the change
between this one and this one is just
one bit the change between this one and
this one is just one bit this one and
this one is just one bit so what I do I
have a mouse click function that takes
you know whenever I say let's see what
happens in between these two the
difference between those two is one one
bit but when you project those into the
bigger space the difference between
those two is four bits and if I vary
those four bits now in between those two
I could see unfortunately you can't see
that but we could see this and you see
how it changes from this particular
behavior which is just solid to the
class four behavior over here and you
will be able to see all the phases that
it goes through as it changes the
different bits into this which means
that this is actually projected into the
bigger space and is still showing that
they are neighbors in terms of the
behavior so these are not completely you
know very very different which is if if
it was true that they run the that the
distribution of the behavior was random
I could probably find some other ones
really really different in between but I
don't and most of the places that I
click on like this one here you will see
that it just smoothly changes in between
so that indicates at least this is a
peek into the higher space
that they are still continuing with that
kind of behavior so this is sort of a
preview into looking into the bigger
space and I wish I said I wish we could
actually look at it a little bit closer
another thing that I had and let me see
if I can just quickly I know that I'm
sort of running out of time let me
change this in here to a single one I'm
gonna initialize all the cellular
automata a single one is the
initialization and it is something that
if you look at most of the displace of
the 256 elementary cellular automata
they're displaced from 0 to 255 because
there is no recently or how you put them
in any other way but when you put them
this way and hopefully it will show soon
before they kick me out of here you will
see that there is a column and it's
coming yes
I like the lollipop there you go
so if you look at this column over here
you see the sierpinski behavior and the
same thing you see the complement which
will go
what are you not right over here
oh no this is I just changed the
necessarily the initial conditions you
know and then he gives me that that
particular column has the sierpinski on
that so it shows that there is some
correlation there is something that is
meaningful and into this reordering
alright so I just to finish off with
this you know we find that for this
parameterization it gives you a good
idea how to arrange the rules and that
you can see how the similar behavior
actually cluster together and we're able
to see where you transition in between
those well I can see for instance if you
have no activity in one of the
primitives your class behavior is going
to be class one and I actually tried
this and somebody else's friend of mine
he's got our experiments with class with
k equal to three foot three colors and I
asked him okay
take this primitive he actually did it
based on all the things that we've
talked about before and I said take this
primitive and put no activity on it and
Henke try it with the other one this is
the seven trillion space and he tried
and tried and tried and all he got was
class one so that was sort of confirming
that but one of the next steps that I
want to do is create a way to explore
the bigger spaces to confirm that we can
actually that we have this structure and
that it will continue to do that and I'm
thinking perhaps a Pacolet with all this
the different functions etc that I have
created you know to put them in there
and this is it would be available and
the path the ball and here's actually
the code you know that you can run with
this an experiment if you actually do
this on a regular notebook you're
actually able to see some other things a
little bit up close and that's what I
wanted to share with you
you